las bombas rusas dejaron de caer sobre
severodonezk pero las secuelas de la
guerra se hacen evidentes en cada
esquina de esta ciudad industrial de
lugansk la gran mayoría huyó pero los
pocos residentes que se quedaron tratan
de reconstruir sus vidas
estamos haciendo bolsos por primera vez
en cuatro meses un poco de vida
tranquila ahora podemos conseguir algo
de comida
hace 20 días que nos instalamos aquí es
una antigua oficina de los bomberos
las condiciones son algo mejores o un
poco más limpias pero la vuelta a una
cierta calma viene acompañada de un
miedo constante a lo que deparará el
futuro muchos sobreviven sin luz ni agua
corriente y se sienten abandonados a
tener 60 años no es la edad para empezar
de nuevo mis hijos no volverán aquí
teniendo un bebé de un año que cuidar no
sé
y todo se ha puesto patas arriba a nivel
mundial es muy doloroso romper con la
familia con la que ha sido inseparable
toda tu vida y encontrarte sola casi en
la calle porque cada noche es un reto y
no hay donde ir
tras la captura de severodonezk el
objetivo del ejército ruso ahora es el
asalto de la ciudad vecinal y seasons
las fuerzas prorrusas aseguran haber
rodeado ya el último bastión de
resistencia en la provincia de lugansk
pero las fuerzas ucranianas lo niegan y
dicen que los combates continúan